- You're busy with,
like, this amazing record
that I'm very excited about.
I got to sing on it.
(audience cheering)
And, I'm very excited for ya'll to hear it
because I only got to hear
the songs you let me hear,
that I was singing on.
And then I got the record and I just,
literally, you never fail
to impress me with like,
your voice, it's insane.
Like literally, like it's
insane how talented you are.
- Thank you for saying that.
- Like, your record is amazing
and you know what I love about it
is you stick to country music.
It sounds like country music that we love.
- Well, it's what I grew up
on, I mean, it's what I love,
it's the music that I was influenced by.
I'm a big Linda Ronstadt fan,
- Yes.
and that stuff has fiddles
and steel guitars all over it.
- She crossed genres, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that was really cool.
- Totally. So, I'm not a
traditional country singer,
but I definitely fall
in the country category.
And I just want to tell you guys,
when Kelly came in to sing on the record,
I've been in every interview
I've been doing this week
about the album release.
I'm like, what is it about
Kelly? I'm like, she's not real,
like, she's not normal,
like, she's just amazing.
- (laughs) She's crazy.
- And she comes in and she just, you know,
I hear this high strong harmony
and I know I'm not going to sing it,
and I'm like, Kelly,
can you come over here and do this for me?
And it's just amazing what you bring.
And I know you could probably,
everyone you sing with you
make them sound better,
but I love our voices together.
- Oh my god, I do too!
- I love singing with you.
- Yeah, let's do more.
- Let's do more.
(laughs)
(audience cheering)
What's funny is after the first one
we got to record together
was "PrizeFighter."
And I got there and I had no idea
that her husband was going
to be, like, producing it.
(laughs)
And I was like, "Uhhh." (laughs)
And I got in the studio,
and I'll tell you,
I've never been more
nervous about sounding good
because I was like, you're there already,
that was nerve wracking enough.
And then your husband who's, you know,
Garth fricking Brooks
walks in and he's like--
(audience cheering)
And literally he was producing me.
I was peeing my pants.
(laughs)
I was like, this is the
worst. But anyway, I--
- He was trolling my session
to try to get you to work with him.
- Oh my gosh!
- That's totally what
he was doing. (laughs)
Well, I was literally about to die
'cause I was so nervous! Both of you!
I mean you're just such this
power couple and it's like,
"Uhhh"
- Oh, please.
If you go back and listen to
the end of "PrizeFighter,"
I don't know if you remember
this at the end we were,
there were these licks at the end,
and so we were kind of doing
these answers to each other.
And I remember that I had
done something and you went in
and then you did your lick and I'm like,
"Let me go back in there." (sniffles)
Like, give me another shot at it.
(laughs)
And so, I went back in and did it again,
and then Kelly said,
"Let me go back in there
"and give it another shot." (laughs)
- I was very nervous. But
he's actually really cool.
I was wondering, does he ever
crash your girls' nights?
Does he--
- He doesn't--
- 'Cause he seems funny like that.
- He's a little afraid of
that many women together,
so he really doesn't,
but if he's around he'll open the wine.
But he really wants to be gone, like,
I think it scares him a little bit.
- Really?
- As it should, you know.
- Women, a bunch of women.
(laughs)
- And here's something else
about you men! (laughs)
No, doesn't. Yeah (laughs)
- It's like a designing
women episode (laughs)
You're ruining everything! (laughs)
That's amazing.
Okay so, I know that
whatever you cook sometimes,
you're a fabulous cook. She is.
I've gone to her house she makes--
(audience cheering)
And she gives you wine!
It's the most amazing experience.
But one thing I found out
actually was the fact that when,
he cooks sometimes, right?
Garth cooks sometimes?
- He does. He does.
- Okay. And he he's like, very
perfectionist at it, right?
He's pretty good, right?
- He's pretty good. I
wouldn't say perfectionist.
He doesn't follow a recipe,
he pretty much like,
will throw things together
that maybe go together,
and then he thinks it's fabulous
and takes a picture of it.
(laughs)
I call him "Gartha Stewart" because he's--
- (laughs) That's amazing!
That's (mumbles) I love that
you call him Gartha Stewart!
- He's very impressed, like
look I made this sandwich,
I took a picture of it, and I'm
like, that's awesome, honey.
- Yeah, and you're like,
meanwhile, you're like
look I have a cooking show
and I'm badass at it (laughs)
- Well, but I'll be like,
"Can you open this jar of pickles?"
And like, "Well, I have
my own cooking show."
I'm like, really? Seriously?
(laughs)
- Stay in your lane!
- Right!
- Gartha!
(laughs)
I just found that amazing.
I found that amazing.
So here's the thing, I
love the "Every Girl."
Like, tell me why you chose
that name for your record,
that song, like tell me, where
did "Every Girl" come from?
- The truth is--
- I love it.
- Thank you very much. The truth is,
well you are every girl.
(laughs)
The truth is that I went in
to make a record for fun.
I'm 54 years old, I'm a woman.
My expectations of what was
going to happen with this record
were not super high, (laughs)
so I was just like, I just
want to make a record I love.
And I wasn't thinking about singles.
I wasn't thinking about radio, at all.
- That's what we should be doing.
- Which is what we should be doing.
If you want to call yourself an artist,
you make art and that's what you do.
And then you figure
out what to do with it.
And, this song was one of
the first ones I heard,
and I just liked it. I liked what it said.
Basically, it has a line that says,
"You got this, baby,
so what if you don't."
I love that line because it's like,
we're always trying to be so perfect
and it's really nice when we're told,
"It's okay to not be perfect."
- Yeah.
- And then, it just kind
of, when my team heard it,
they were like, "We're going
to radio and this is the song."
And I've been more shocked than anybody
that it's getting played on the radio,
which it is, so I'm like, "Woohoo!"
- That's what I love about your record.
It sounds country, it's what
it's supposed to be like,
and, honestly in this
time in country music,
like I grew up in the '90s,
like listening to music,
there were so many of ya'll!
There were so many great,
like, country women.
And like, right now, it's
hard just to be a woman,
to get played on country music,
and then you're saying, "Oh, I'm 54."
It's hard to do that at 54 to get played.
- Right, right. It's
just all these layers of,
and I don't understand that
either because people think,
well maybe country music is just behind.
But in the '90s, there were
so many female artists.
- Oh my gosh, I could name a plethora!
- Yeah.
- So what happened? I have
this conversation all the time
with all the girls I know
in country music, I'm like,
what's happening?
- I think it's my fault. I
left town, I moved to Oklahoma
for 14 years.
- Yeah, why did you ruin it?
Why did she ruin it?
- (laughs) I ruin everything.
(audience clapping)
When I moved to Oklahoma
and married Garth,
and we raised the girls,
and then when we came back,
I was shocked! I was like,
what has happened? I know--
- There's like two that are played.
- Right. And I don't
really know the answer.
I do know that living in Nashville now,
the girls have kind of banded together.
And it's been really cool
to see generationally,
like, the young girls who grew up
on "She's In Love With The
Boy," and then my generation,
and then we've got Reba and Loretta.
Everybody's, kind of, this girl club,
and the conversations now
being had out loud and loudly,
and the men in our
industry who support that,
like Garth and Blake and Luke,
who have spoken out about it,
that's when change happens.
So, I think, right now,
everybody's just being really loud.
The CMAs this year are going
to be hosted by three women
for the first time in
the history of the CMAs.
(audience cheering)
- Is it Carrie, with Reba and Dolly?
- Yeah.
And it isn't against the
men, it's not saying that.
It's just saying, we're here,
we're not going anywhere.
- Yeah. But let's team up!
Let's make beautiful music.
Let's make something happen.